[Music]
now you're on the FXX show the league
and uh and what is that like because you
must have a lot of sports fans that are
now Nick croll fans but you're kind of a
sports fan right I mean I grew up yeah I
grew up playing sports and loving Sports
and then like faded out um in high
school and then in college um and then I
uh got on the league and and started to
follow football and and so it's
interesting because there are definitely
people who watch the show
who I think wouldn't normally be uh fans
of mine um and probably don't think and
I I guess I don't come across as
athletic
um I'd put it fair 5050 what do you guys
think do I do I seem like an
athlete someone audibly kick all your
asses um you you seem to
me like someone they tried to make you
play offensive line in high school yeah
and you were horrible
yeah I used to walk down the hallway and
coaches would go cuz I was very tall
they just go why they really would that
really happened and I was like it's
because of yelling like this I don't
want to come to your fake Sports thing
did you ever play any sports no I can't
get into it what about like tennis like
a Nick craw sport is that a Nick craw
sport cucumber sandwich and a quick game
of tennis I mean I would think I would
play CR
but um I um that's that laugh that's the
laugh America will grow to love and hate
um could be love or hate I mean I think
it's a love and hate well we've been in
cars before and you've gone I I'm
instigating a no laugh in the car you've
said no laugh in the car uh yeah well
because it's such a small space and your
laugh is so uh piercingly loud yeah um
that I I'd want to protect my my eard
drums yeah my laugh would be better to
you underwater yeah I would love to see
you laugh underwater and see the bubble
and then the bubble come out of the
water it's like you're
[Music]
like that I would really like that I
would like to see I'd also sort of like
to see you almost drown
yeah not actually drowned I would love
you to live through it yeah cuz you get
a quality monologue
so I almost drowned the other day yeah
yeah yeah we'll be right back I'm
kidding I'm
kidding I forget you can't make that
joke when you're actually on a TV
[Music]
show